Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
L’économie est la discipline reine de notre
temps. Ses concepts et ses sujets connaissent
un large succès dans le débat public. Les
journaux et les chaînes de télévision ont
créé des rubriques spécifiques. Les économistes
exercent leur expertise dans les médias,
l’administration, les partis politiques,
ou encore les entreprises. Les idées économiques
sont désormais indispensables pour comprendre
le monde.
Pour ma part, j’aime beaucoup l’économie,
mais je m’en méfie.
Pourquoi ? Parce que notre société accorde
une confiance excessive — me semble-t-il
— à cette discipline intellectuelle. Depuis
que j’ai étudié l’économie en école
de commerce, je suis même personnellement
rebuté par la mathématisation de la discipline
: cette évolution trahit, à mes yeux, la
volonté de s’arroger l’autorité intellectuelle
des sciences dures.
« L'économiste est celui qui est toujours
capable d'expliquer ex post pourquoi il s'est,
une fois de plus, trompé. » — Bernard
Maris
Je trouve cependant les idées économiques
intéressantes et utiles.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
* Comment définir l’économie ?
* D’où vient l’économie ?
* L’économie est-elle vraiment une science
?
* Quelles sont les branches de l’économie
* Qui sont les économistes ?
Comment définir l’économie ?
Que signifie le mot « économie » ?
Le mot a d’abord un sens banal dans l’existence
individuelle. Le café est certes cher chez
Starbucks (aux alentours de 5 euros), mais
s’en priver, c’est peut-être réaliser
une « économie » inutile au regard d’autres
enjeux financiers, comme l’achat d’une
voiture ou d’un appartement. Une économie,
c’est donc une réduction, voire une absence
de dépense.
« Il n’y a pas de petites économies. » — Adage
populaire.
Si ce n’est certes pas le sens de l’adjectif
dans l’expression « culture économique
», il y a déjà l’idée de l’optimisation
de la valeur. D’ailleurs, on peut aussi
économiser — de manière figurée — le
temps, l’énergie, les efforts, la volonté,
etc. Mais le sens qui nous intéresse, c’est
celui de l’économie comme discipline intellectuelle.
Du point de vue de l’étymologie, le terme
« économie » vient de la jonction des mots
grecs oikos, « la maison, le domaine », et
nemo, « administrer ». Dans la Grèce antique,
un oikos est plus précisément une unité
d’habitation (qui regroupe les parents et
les esclaves) et de production (agricole ou
artisanale) — et la gestion de cet ensemble
avait une importance particulière à l’époque.
L’économie, ce serait donc étymologiquement
l’administration du domaine. Mais l’unité
de référence peut aussi être la ville,
le pays, voire le monde — et la définition
varie selon l’ensemble considéré.
Dans le sens le plus global, l’économie
est donc la création et la répartition de
la valeur dans un groupe humain.
Il faut encore distinguer deux dimensions
dans ma définition :
* le processus même de création et de répartition
de la valeur ;
* l’optimisation de ce processus (grâce
à la réflexion).
En tant que discipline intellectuelle, l’économie
se définit donc par son but : optimiser la
création et la répartition de la valeur
dans un groupe humain.
Quels sont les concepts les plus importants
?
Certains mots reviennent souvent lorsque l’on
parle d’économie. En effet, la réflexion
économique présuppose une certaine manière
de voir le monde ; c’est pourquoi elle nous
offre une batterie de concepts pour interpréter
la réalité.
Elle identifie tout d’abord certains acteurs
:
* les ménages, c’est-à-dire les personnes
partageant le même domicile ;
* les sociétés non financières (entreprises)
;
* les sociétés financières (banques, assurances,
etc.) ;
* les administrations publiques (État, collectivités
locales, organismes de sécurité sociale,
etc.) ;
* les acteurs économiques situés
à l’étranger.
Chaque acteur a une certaine fonction et dispose
de certaines ressources. Par exemple, les
ménages consomment des biens et services
grâce à leurs revenus.
« Le but de l'économie n'est pas le travail,
mais la consommation. » — Alfred Sauvy
La réflexion économique met en évidence
5 grandes fonctions :
1. la production, c’est-à-dire la création
de la valeur ;
2. la consommation, c’est-à-dire la satisfaction
d’un besoin ou d’un désir grâce à la
valeur produite (généralement un bien ou
un service) ;
3. la répartition, c’est-à-dire l’affectation
de la valeur aux acteurs ;
4. l’épargne, c’est-à-dire la mise en
réserve de la valeur ;
5. l’investissement, c’est-à-dire l’affectation
de la valeur dans le but d’engendrer un
futur surcroît de valeur.
Depuis le XXe siècle, on distingue 3 grands
secteurs de production :
1. le secteur primaire : toutes les activités
d’exploitation des ressources naturelles
(l’agriculture, la pêche, les forêts,
les mines, ou les gisements) ;
2. le secteur secondaire : toutes les activités
de transformation des matières premières
(les industries manufacturières, la construction)
;
3. le secteur tertiaire : toutes les activités
de service, marchant ou non-marchand.
La valeur circule dans un groupe humain grâce
à la procédure de l’échange. Celui-ci
peut être direct — c’est le troc — ou
indirect, par l’intermédiaire de la monnaie.
Il est particulièrement favorisé en un lieu
spécial, le marché. C’est là qu’une
offre de biens et services rencontre une demande.
Lorsque cette rencontre fixe librement le
prix du bien ou du service, on parle alors
d’une « économie de marché ».
« L'homme est un animal qui fait des affaires.
Un chien n'échange pas son os contre celui
d'un autre. » — Sydney Smith
Enfin, le débat public se focalise sur quelques
paramètres :
* la croissance est l’augmentation de la
valeur économique produite dans un pays (le
PIB) pendant une certaine période ;
* le chômage est la proportion de la population
qui ne travaille pas bien qu’elle soit en
capacité de travailler ;
* l’inflation est la hausse générale et
durable des prix ;
* le pouvoir d’achat est la capacité d’un
ménage à acheter des biens et services grâce
à son revenu ;
* la dette publique est l’ensemble des engagements
financiers contractés par l'État.
D’où vient l’économie ?
Pour répondre à cette question, il faut
distinguer la réflexion économique telle
que nous la connaissons au XXIe siècle, d’une
part ; et la pensée économique antérieure.
À quand remonte la pensée économique ?
On peut probablement trouver des idées économiques
depuis qu’on peut trouver des idées, c’est-à-dire
depuis que les hommes pensent leur réalité.
Et pour cause, l’économie est une dimension
primordiale de la vie quotidienne d’un groupe
humain, qu’elle qu’en soit la taille.
Il dispose de ressources dont il doit faire
le meilleur usage possible.
« Peu de richesses ménagées avec économie
valent mieux que de grands trésors mal employés.
» — Proverbe oriental
Historiquement, c’est le développement
du commerce qui a stimulé la conceptualisation.
Dès le IVe millénaire av. J.-C, les marchands
de la civilisation mésopotamienne mettent
au point une terminologie particulière pour
penser leur activité. Ils comprennent déjà
la logique du marché, l’avantage de s’associer
pour partager le risque, et la valeur de la
prudence dans les affaires. On trouve également
une pensée économique dans les anciennes
civilisations chinoise et indienne, mais la
reflexion sert cette fois-ci l’action de
l’État (et non pas des intérêts privés)
— elle relève globalement de la science
politique.
Du point de vue intellectuel, la pensée économique
aurait donc 2 sources :
1. l’administration des affaires ;
2. la philosophie politique.
L’économie n’est donc pas une discipline
intellectuelle en tant que telle. D’un côté,
les hommes d’affaires, certainement très
pragmatiques, approfondissent les questions
économiques pour s’enrichir ; de l’autre,
les philosophes et les hommes d’État y
réfléchissent avec une plus grande ampleur
de vue, pour exercer le pouvoir et atteindre
des buts moins prosaïques, telle l’harmonie
sociale.
Quand l’économie prend-elle son visage
moderne ?
L’économie telle que nous la connaissons
naît au XVIIIe siècle. Cette césure s’explique
par le décollage de la croissance : le monde
a vécu jusque-là dans une économie de pénurie
marquée par les disettes à répétition.
Mais comme on l’a vu dans la leçon sur
la révolution scientifique, le revenu par
habitant décolle avec la révolution industrielle.
Or, cette évolution est la preuve que l’augmentation
de la population n’entraîne pas forcément
un appauvrissement systématique, et qu’au
contraire elle peut stimuler la croissance.
Ainsi, sur le plan intellectuel, c’est l’idée
de la croissance qui fait passer la pensée
économique à un niveau supérieur.
À cette époque, on parle désormais d’«
économie politique » (political economy)
pour désigner la réflexion sur la création
et la répartition de la richesse dans un
pays. L’idée s’impose alors que la fortune
de l’État dépend de la prospérité de
la nation.
« Pauvres paysans, pauvre royaume ; pauvre
royaume, pauvre roi. » — François Quesnay
Les hommes qui, comme François Quesnay, mènent
ce genre de réflexion, commencent à se dire
« économistes ». Ils ne cherchent plus
seulement à prescrire des recettes ; ils
veulent désormais, dans l’esprit de la
science moderne, comprendre les phénomènes
économiques afin d’en déduire des solutions.
L’économie est-elle vraiment une science
?
La réponse dépend bien évidemment de la
définition de la science. Comme mon but est
simplement de vous donner une vue d’ensemble
du débat, je ne vais pas entrer dans les
détails, mais seulement vous présenter les
principaux arguments.
Quels sont les arguments pour ?
En premier lieu, l’économie suit la méthode
de la science moderne :
* elle pratique le doute pour éviter le dogme
;
* elle essaie de découvrir des lois ;
* elle met ses hypothèses à l’épreuve
de l’expérience ;
* elle favorise le débat dans une communauté
de savants.
Ensuite, elle imite les sciences dures. Les
économistes académiquement reconnus au XXIe
siècle raisonnent comme des physiciens. Ils
ont adopté la même démarche globale, le
même langage mathématique, et certains transposent
même carrément les nouveaux résultats de
la physique en économie (Irving Fisher a
par exemple transféré les concepts de la
physique newtonienne).
« À l’instar des physiciens, les économistes
construisent leurs théories avec la précision
que permet l’usage des mathématiques. » — Nicholas
Gregory Mankiw
Enfin, l’économiste moderne fait un large
usage des statistiques. Grâce à la puissance
de calcul des ordinateurs, il récolte, tel
un expérimentateur, de grandes quantités
de données et les passe à la moulinette
d'un algorithme afin de vérifier les relations
mathématiques qu’il théorise. Les techniques
de mesure des grandeurs économiques — ce
qu’on appelle « l’économétrie » — n’ont
cessé de se développer depuis les années
1960.
La scientificité de l’économie est cependant
une prétention fragile…
Quels sont les arguments contre ?
« Le développement de l’économie réelle
n’a rien à voir avec la science économique.
Bien qu’on les enseigne comme s’il s’agissait
de mathématiques, les théories économiques
n’ont jamais eu la moindre utilité pratique.
» — Karl Popper
Tout d’abord, les faits démentent la fiabilité
du savoir économique. On peut raisonner par
l'absurde : si l'économie était bien une
science au même titre que les mathématiques
ou la physique, alors elle ne commettrait
pas d’erreurs aussi énormes que celles
qui pavent l’histoire économique (notamment
à propos des crises). Par exemple, 8 jours
avant l'effondrement de Wall Street en octobre
1929, Irving Fischer était formel : pas de
krach boursier en vue, tout va bien !
« Pourquoi Dieu a-t-il créé les économistes
? Pour qu’on prenne les météorologues
au sérieux. » — Blague d’économiste
Ensuite, l’économie n’a pas la cohérence
d’une science. La réflexion économique
n’évolue pas dans un « paradigme » au
sens de Thomas Kuhn, c’est-à-dire qu’il
n’existe pas une unité de pensée relativement
stable autour d’un cadre théorique consensuel.
Au contraire, différentes « écoles », comme
les classiques et les keynésiens, sont en
concurrence, qui défendent des lois contradictoires,
voire incompatibles.
Plus fondamentalement, enfin, l’économie
ne pourrait pas être une science. Pourquoi
donc ? Parce que son objet est l’activité
humaine. Par conséquent, les « expériences
» sur lesquelles elle s’appuie ne peuvent
être reproduites en raison ne serait-ce que
de la variation, dans le temps et dans l'espace,
des préférences des individus. L’économiste
français Jacques Sapir parle des « trous
noirs » de la science économique.
« L’économie n’a jamais pu démontrer
l’existence de lois économiques. » — Jacques
Sapir, Les trous noirs de la science économique
Quelles sont les branches de l’économie
?
Qu’est-ce que la « microéconomie » et
la « macroéconomie » ?
La différence tient à l’échelle d’analyse
: le préfixe « micro- » vient du grec mikros,
qui signifie « petit », tandis que « macro-
» vient du grec makros, qui signifie « grand
».
La microéconomie étudie donc le comportement
des acteurs individuelles, tels que le consommateur
ou l’entreprise, ainsi que leurs interactions.
L’idée de départ de ce courant est que
l’individu cherche à maximiser son utilité
dans un contexte, en fonction de ses propres
ressources et de l’action des autres acteurs.
Les microéconomistes s’intéressent à
tout un tas de sujets, de l’achat d’une
voiture d’occasion à la valeur des diplômes,
en passant par les avantages du mariage.
« La morale représente la façon dont les
gens aimeraient que le monde fonctionne, tandis
que l'économie représente la façon dont
il fonctionne réellement. » — Steven D.
Levitt, Freakonomics
La macroéconomie, elle, étudie les grands
agrégats économiques, tels la production,
l’investissement, la consommation, le taux
de chômage, ou encore l’inflation. Les
médias parlent beaucoup de ces grandeurs
parce qu’elles permettent d’évaluer la
performance de l’économie d’un pays.
Les macroéconomistes peuvent mettre en évidence
la possibilité d’améliorer un paramètre
en en sacrifiant un autre (par exemple, réduire
le chômage en acceptant une hausse des prix).
C’est John Maynard Keynes qui, dans la première
moitié du XXe siècle, a radicalisé la distinction
entre les deux échelles de l’analyse économique.
Il a repris par là la césure qui apparaissait
alors entre la mécanique quantique (qui
concerne l'infiniment petit) et la mécanique
relativiste (qui porte sur l'infiniment grand).
Quelles sont les principales écoles ?
En essayant d’être synthétique et impartial
— c’est-à-dire en ne disqualifiant pas
les courants qui nous déplaisent — je pense
qu’on peut distinguer 3 écoles principales
dans l’histoire de la pensée économique.
1° L’école classique apparaît en Europe
au XVIIIe siècle : c’est avec elle que
commence véritablement la « science » économique.
Les auteurs les plus emblématiques en sont
Adam Smith (1723-1790), considéré comme
le « père » de l’économie, et David
Ricardo (1772-1823). Sur le plan des idées,
cette école est libérale, c’est-à-dire
qu’elle est plutôt défavorable à l’intervention
de l’État dans l’économie.
« Le libéralisme, c'est le renard libre
dans le poulailler libre. » — Karl Marx
2° L’école marxiste naît en Europe au
milieu du XIXe siècle, à partir de l’œuvre
de Karl Marx. Elle se définit par opposition
à l’école classique, qu’elle disqualifie
comme une idéologie bourgeoise servant à
justifier l’exploitation des classes laborieuses.
Sur le plan des idées, elle est anticapitaliste
parce qu’elle considère que la propriété
privée du capital (surtout les machines,
à l’époque) est un principe injuste qui
maintient et développe l’inégalité, et
donc le malheur du grand nombre, dans la société.
3° L’école keynésienne est la fille d’un
livre publié en 1936, la Théorie générale
de l'emploi, de l'intérêt et de la monnaie
de Keynes. Celui-ci s’oppose lui aussi à
l’école classique, mais sans remettre en
cause le capitalisme. Son idée fondamentale
est que l’activité économique est instable
à court terme, en vertu de quoi l’État
a la responsabilité d’intervenir afin de
réduire les effets de court terme d’une
crise sur le bien-être de la population.
« À long terme, nous serons tous morts.
Les économistes se fixent une tâche peu
utile s’ils peuvent seulement nous dire
que, lorsque l’orage sera passé, l’océan
sera plat à nouveau. » — Keynes
Je vous expliquerai plus en détail les idées
de ces trois écoles dans la suite du module,
et vous verrez aussi qu’il existe beaucoup
d’autres courants.
Quelles sont les sous-disciplines de l’économie
?
La liste est longue, potentiellement interminable,
parce qu’on peut mettre beaucoup de choses
après « économie ». Je vais donc nommer
celles que vous devez connaître en priorité
pour votre culture générale.
Les sous-disciplines les plus importantes
sont :
* l’économique publique, qui étudie les
politiques qu’un État peut mener afin de
favoriser le développement économique et
le bien-être de sa population ;
* l’économie monétaire, qui étudie l’influence
de la monnaie sur l’activité économique
;
* l’économie du développement, qui étudie
les déterminants de la pauvreté ainsi que
les moyens d’en sortir ;
* l’économie internationale, qui étudie
les rapports économiques (commerciaux, financiers,
et monétaires) entre différents pays ;
* l’économie comportementale, qui étudie
les comportements des individus dans des situations
économiques ;
* l’économie des organisations, qui étudie
l’influence de l’organisation sur l’activité
économique.
Qui sont les économistes ?
Comment devient-on économiste ?
Comme dans la plupart des disciplines à prétention
scientifique, le statut d’économiste repose
sur l’obtention d’un diplôme (généralement
un doctorat) et sur la publication d’articles
dans des revues scientifiques.
La grande majorité des universités et des
grandes écoles ont un département d’économie
ainsi que la capacité à délivrer des diplômes
en économie. Cependant, le titre d’« économiste
» n’est pas protégé (contrairement à
celui de « médecin », par exemple) et certains
économistes mondialement reconnus n’ont
pas de diplôme dans la discipline, à l’instar
du psychologue Daniel Kahneman, qui a pourtant
obtenu le prix Nobel d’économie en 2002.
C’est donc la reconnaissance des pairs qui
importe.
Les universités les plus réputées au monde
pour l’économie sont toutes aux États-Unis
: Harvard et le MIT dans l'agglomération
de Boston, Stanford et Berkeley en Californie,
ou encore l’université de Chicago, très
influente depuis les années 1980. En Europe,
on peut aussi citer la LSE (London School
of Economics), et en France la TSE (Toulouse
School of Economics), où officie Jean Tirole,
le prix Nobel 2014.
Les revues les plus réputées à l’international
sont le « Top Five » :
* l’American Economic Review ;
* Econometrica ;
* le Journal of Political Economy ;
* le Quarterly Journal of Economics ;
* le Review of Economic Studies.
Qu’est-ce que le « métier » d’économiste
?
Pour exercer leur métier, les économistes
ont plusieurs options :
* enseigner dans une université, comme Thomas
Piketty à l’EHESS, ou une école de commerce,
comme Jean-Marc Daniel à l’ESCP ;
* travailler dans un think tank, comme Maxime
Sbaihi à Génération Libre ;
* travailler dans une institution financière
(une banque ou une compagnie d’assurance),
comme Patrick Artus à Natixis ;
* travailler dans un organisme international
(tel le FMI ou la Banque mondiale), comme
Benoît Cœuré à la BCE de 2012 à 2019.
En France, on peut distinguer 3 profils d’économistes
:
1. les universitaires, formés et enseignants
à l’université, qui ont une approche plus
littéraire que les économistes de réputation
mondiale ;
2. les praticiens de l’économie, des hauts
fonctionnaires passés par l’ENA et l’Inspection
des finances (comme Emmanuel Macron), souvent
sans diplôme spécifiquement économique
ni lien avec le monde académique, et qui
mettent en place la politique économique
de la France ;
3. les mathématiciens de l’économie, généralement
issus d’écoles d’ingénieur (le graal
étant Polytechnique ou l’École normale
supérieure) et diplômés de l’ENSAE.
Aujourd’hui, un économiste est aussi un
intellectuel. Il intervient volontiers dans
le débat public et l’autorité récente
de sa discipline donne du poids à son discours,
en apparence dépourvu d’idéologie. En
écrivant des livres et en prenant la parole
à la télévision, il aide les gens à comprendre
le monde dans lequel ils vivent. Certains
économistes, comme Jacques Sapir ou Jean-Marc
Daniel, jouissent par ailleurs d’une grande
culture générale.
Pour Friedrich Hayek, prix Nobel 1974, un
économiste doit être un intellectuel polyvalent
:
« Personne ne saurait être un grand économiste
en étant seulement économiste et je suis
même tenté d'ajouter qu'un économiste
qui n'est qu'économiste peut devenir une
gêne, si ce n'est un danger. »
Depuis 1969, l’Académie royale des sciences
de Suède remet chaque année, en octobre,
un prix Nobel d’économie. Même si l’authenticité
du prix est contestée — la discipline n’apparaît
pas dans le testament d’Alfred Nobel — et
si les choix de l’Académie suscitent parfois
la controverse, il s’agit tout de même
d’une des récompenses les plus prestigieuses
de la discipline (et elle fait gagner 900
000 euros au récipiendaire). Quatre Français
l’ont déjà obtenu : Gérard Debreu en
1983, Maurice Allais en 1988, Jean Tirole
en 2014, et Esther Duflo en 2019.
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.